Let's uh let's jump to this cultural
story this is a this is an interesting
one we have this uh tweet I saw this
image from icons women Hannah aaronsman
says I have decided to end my cycling
career at my last race at the recent UCI
cyclocross national championships in the
elite women's category I came in fourth
place flanked on either side by male
writers awarded third and fifth places
my sister and family sobbed as they
watched a man finish in front of me
having witnessed several physical
interactions with him throughout the
race
so this is this is the photo was the
woman crying as she's quitting because
she was denied the podium by a male
athlete there's another story where
another male has won I think like 15
races yeah like 15 to 15 or some
ridiculous number in New York right yeah
I just won one in New York and uh I feel
bad for this woman but I think she's
doing the right thing in quitting and I
think all of these women need to quit
and maybe make a new league maybe make
the female division or something it's a
great example of the leader that steps
out of the herd and says this is insane
we need to stop doing this and she's
going to pay an insane price she's
giving up her dream and her career to do
that but I but I think the tide is
turning I think the insanity people are
starting to say what are we doing here
well yeah we have a story here from uh
timcast.com World Athletics Council bans
biological male athletes from from
competing against females officials say
the policy update is to protect the
Integrity of female Athletics so it's
starting to happen I mean that's that's
big huh yeah I mean especially this
issue I I ran track in high school so
it's a sport I care a lot about but
there are there was a group of um track
athletes in Connecticut that were some
of the first to file a lawsuit and say
you can't let male biologically male
athletes compete with us because it does
take away our right to compete in a
sport like you are flying in the face of
something that theoretically feminism
fought for and and those two males were
not undergoing hormone therapy or
anything like that they were just males
who were like I want to compete against
the females because I'm a woman they
said fine and they kept winning every
race and breaking records yeah and it's
especially like on the high school level
it means that you don't uh show up on
the rosters that college coaches get so
you miss out on scholarship
opportunities like if if uh you are an
elite athlete competing at that level
you can't expect a coach to look at the
list and say oh well you know these
these names all appear female to me so
why would I question this right and
especially if we're supposed to treat uh
biological men who had identify as women
the same way then you are literally
giving away spots on teams and
educational dollars to them when these
girls have trained for so long to get to
that place it I mean it seems like to me
it seems like common sense but I
understand our culture has created a
different narrative around that well I I
feel like uh you know Matt was saying
the insanity is starting to be pushed
back against I think we're starting to
win on this front so maybe that's a good
thing maybe the United States can
finally get its act together there was a
a couple big moments one was when
jankuger of The Young Turks agreed with
Bernie Sanders saying we want equality
of opportunity not outcome that's like
okay welcome back to the mix and then we
have I think I have the Tweet right here
anna casparin of The Young Turks tweeted
I'm a woman please don't ever refer to
me as a person with a uterus birthing
person or person who menstruates how do
people not realize how degrading this is
you can support the transgender
Community without doing this ish and of
course she got ripped to shreds the left
one after her and started screaming at
her and insulting her they're calling
them the young turfs now inside of Young
Turks but I'm like well you know what if
The Young Turks are pushing back on the
insanity gradually I'll accept it I will
take it and maybe we're going to start
winning more ground in the culture War
that's a good thing man and talk about
if this is another one I think that
there's really no winning or losing it's
about can we co-exist the victory is can
we all win and when you see Anna went on
Ben Shapiro's show a month ago I didn't
know that and they had a great
conversation it's fascinating to talk
about Medicare for all I mean it's legit
and then I just saw Sam Cedar went on
valuetainment so it's like people that
you would consider from the left and the
right are coming together to talk I
think a lot of it's because this this
this banking Fiasco you know the economy
hitting its Breaking Point people are
like what choice do I have at this point
I think there are probably always been
people who say like hey this is
something that we should not we should
not pursue so because it's one history
history month I've been writing about
anti-feminists and I this week I
published a profile of uh Camille Paglia
which I'm definitely pronouncing her
name wrong but she is an academic at
University of Arts in Philadelphia and
she gets this rep reputation of being
you're not even of being the
anti-feminist feminist she said you know
I was a feminist in the 1960s and we
fought for our rights to be free we
fought so that we wouldn't have to have
curfews in college dorms we could risk
the right to be raped and attacked on
campus Because we wanted the right to
like take care of ourselves and not be
in the protection of men or whatever
else and one of the things that she has
gotten in trouble for in more recent
years is saying you know
you guys should pay attention to biology
you guys seem really interested in
science except for when it applies to
this issue and she says you know you
can't your biology says you can't just
suddenly decide you're a different
gender and this has ousted her from the
feminist Community I mean she still
identifies as a feminist but feminists
don't want her there even though she's
one of the most noted academics in this
ideology it's crazy she's the most legit
feminist out there and my wife and I
have this this fantastic argument and I
always lose arguments with my wife but I
consider myself a radical feminist and I
see the comments are going to freak out
here my wife considers herself an
anti-feminist because we both believe in
really strong women that have the right
to determine their own destiny and
that's what feminism used to be about
and you know my childhood intellectual
hero was a woman Ein Rand she turned me
on to a lot of these ideas and she was a
badass who fled uh the Soviet Union
after her father's business was stolen
when she was still a teenager and she
ended up in Hollywood as a scriptwriter
that's badass and that's my sort of
heroic view of what women can be in
modern feminism and all of this stuff
we're talking about it is so
anti-feminist in every single way and
and back to Anna for just a second
that's that's a heroic stand that she's
taking because she's taking on her own
audience her own woke audience is is
trying to destroy her and you know it's
one thing for for us to criticize that
my audience isn't going to get mad at me
if I criticize uh wokism but but she's
got to deal with that yeah
that's a hero The Young Turks probably
lost a lot of money by them coming out
and saying this yeah and I think it's a
good thing and I hope they lose more not
because I want them to suffer or because
I'm trying to be mean but because they
need to free themselves in the shackle
of this cult and if they no longer have
any incentive to try and please these
people and it seems like they're already
shaking that off maybe they'll stop
pushing a lot of that garbage yeah so
good for them I mean what are the odds
that she wants to jump ship anyways
right like if she's gonna take this
dance she must know that yeah he is okay
yeah outright defending her and saying
she's never going to apologize and he
agrees with her so I I do think the main
issue with Young Turks is that they're
duplicitous you know I can respect her
making the statement but they make fake
videos about me and other people all the
time so it's not like I expect them to
ever be good people or anything like
that but again credit what credit is due
yeah we need to we need to make these
gains in the culture war and take what
we can get when we can get it so I don't
know I thought the young turfs was
really funny that is funny I like it
it's less offensive than the Young The
Young Turks like they named their
organization after the Armenian Genocide
it's crazy
I like your take about being uh an
extreme feminist I always say that my
dad is the most is the biggest feminist
I know he's constantly telling me I can
do things that I'm capable I don't like
it it's the worst uh no but I'm being
serious I feel like there are so many
men conservative men that I know who are
advocates for you know strong capable
women and they believe that women are
completely capable it's the victim
mentality that has crept into this
modern iteration of feminism that I just
can't get behind I don't understand why
it would be appealing to anyone I also
just hate giving up words that that are
packed with meaning and value and and
and we always find ourselves like
um
attacking the word justice or attacking
the word democracy or attacking
attacking the word Community because
it's been co-opted to mean something
that it doesn't mean and I think we
should be feminists because we're
pro-women yeah just just to find what
you mean and don't let don't let the
bastards steal our language from us
that's it's we're in the fourth wave of
feminism the word but the word has
different meanings in every wave the
second wave of feminism is the one
you're talking about from the states
when I was raised with my mom I was like
as a very young kid I asked my mom does
feminism mean that women are better than
men she said no feminism means that men
and women are equal and that was all I
needed after it changed my life I was
like okay I get it so right now it
didn't make sense but if you ask a trans
activist
they will use the phrase CIS woman
but they want you they say trans women
are women so just say woman
CIS women however are CIS women you see
what they're doing yeah they are they're
they are taking the the the normative
term woman applying to themselves and
then making CIS women the outlier the
other the reality is if you're a man and
you want to transition to a woman you
can be a trans woman and you're still a
man you never stop being a human you're
still a human like you don't end one to
become the other you become both
so it's very important to realize that
women are women and they can also be
trans men and women at the same time
well trans women is a subcategory of
male exactly so you're a man and a trans
woman or you can be a woman and a trans
man but you don't like lose one when you
try and like Transit you're still the
same you're still a human you never stop
being a man you never stop being a human
you're still I mean even if you identify
as a shoe you're still a human but this
is like where the concept of dead naming
comes in right like if someone says you
know now that I have accepted this
identity and I I believe I'm supposed to
be like this you should never refer to
me and even reference I don't want to
see pictures of this person I was before
I mean they they do feel as though they
can completely leave behind you know
this this part of themselves they can
they can do whatever they want and I'll
do whatever I want but the whole like
this is who I was before like it's still
now you're still you you you are
different and you're still you like it
doesn't
you know it's I I don't know like it's
not like you you're no longer what you
were you're still you're still that and
more now so I
but but Tim's point is like uh we're not
giving up the word woman
that's our word we know what that means
that's our word you can't say it yeah
well no like says hat says there's
they're slurs if they're going to make
the argument that trans women are women
then I'll make the same argument and say
then you can't say CIS woman that's
that's derogatory in the same way you
claim it is so your own logic negates
your right to do so that being said I
mean like trans women
defines something it is a biological
male who identifies as female
there you go end of story you can't then
say you are a woman well you're a trans
woman there's a qualifier for that
because you are different from woman
yeah you can't be a trans woman if
you're a woman you would you have to be
a man to be a trans woman yes
yeah and you have to be a woman to be a
trans man
so they're they're playing with
definitions I think for legal reasons
because if they can switch get the
culture to start arguing that woman
includes males it changes civil rights
law thanks for watching this clip from
the timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time